professor
you've got a [ __ ] well i call that a
football you're going to call that
soccer ball it's a soccer ball to me
whatever it is why have you got it okay
so i want to tell you about soccer balls
actually i want to tell you about
spheres so here's the fact that i want
to tell you
if you have the surface of a sphere like
this you could think the surface of the
earth or something we can divide it up
into pieces
so the way i'm going to do that is using
what are called vertices edges and faces
so vertices are like dots so maybe i'll
put a dot there
and a dot there
edges are going to connect vertices so
here's one edge
and then maybe i'll draw another edge
around the back
and then faces are pieces that are
bounded by the edges so in this picture
the way i've divided it up one face is
the upper hemisphere of the sphere and
the other face is the lower hemisphere
of the sphere
okay so why did i divide it up like that
well i want to use this really cool
thing called the euler characteristic so
if you've watched the video about
brussels sprouts we talked about the
euler characteristic before so this is
going to be the euler characteristic for
a sphere it says that the number of
vertices minus the number of edges plus
the number of faces is always equal to
two so this is a well-known mathematical
fact the euler characteristic is
something we could do this for other
shapes too not just spheres so like we
could take the euler characteristic of
the surface of a donut if you wanted to
so usually we write this letter chi for
the euler characteristic the euler
characteristic of a donut is zero
um and you can take the oil
characteristic of other surfaces too
like have you ever been to uh one of
those do they have these in australia
the water parks with the double inner
tube rides
yeah i love those things okay so if we
consider one of those double inner tubes
that thing has euler characteristic
negative two
so the euler characteristic can be
different for different shapes that we
have for this sphere though the euler
characteristic is always two
and what i mean when i say always is
even if you did the vertices edges and
faces differently like why did i pick
two vertices and two edges and two faces
we'd still get the number two say for
instance like i added some vertices to
this picture so maybe i'd add one at the
north pole and one at the south pole and
i could add some edges too so like an
edge
uh put a vertex here and a vertex here
and we can draw some edges
so see this one's like coming from this
point down to the south pole and this
back point down to the south pole you
might do the same thing
up here
so now we've divided it up in a
different way with vertices edges and
faces but let's count again so i have
one two three four five six vertices now
minus the number of edges so i have um
let's fill in this edge and this edge
because otherwise it's confusing the way
i've drawn it this edge
and this edge okay i gotta count edges
let's make sure we don't forget any one
two three four
five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve
12 edges
and how many faces do we have well on
the top see we have one two and then
there are two more in the back so one
two three four on the top and similarly
one two three four on the bottom so we
have eight faces total
and what do we have we have 14 minus 12
is 2 like we should get so we can do the
vertices edges and faces in lots of
different ways we still get that the
euler characteristic of the sphere is
two i think i think i know where you're
going yeah so for instance we could
divide up the surface of a sphere
in the way it is in a soccer ball so
what what is a soccer ball standard
soccer ball look like so it's tiled with
some pentagons and some hexagons and i'm
going to show you that you can figure
out how many pentagons and hexagons have
to be on the soccer ball using the euler
characteristic shall we do it please so
let's say that p
is going to be the number
of pentagons on a soccer ball
and h
is the number of hexagons the way we're
going to do it is using the euler
characteristic which means we need to
count vertices edges and faces
let's count
faces because that one's the easiest
so the way i'm thinking about this is
that we're dividing it up using these
edges that are naturally on the soccer
ball and the vertices are like these
points where the edges come together and
the faces are the individual pieces how
many faces are there well if there are p
pentagons and h hexagons the number of
faces is just
p plus h
so now let's count i don't know let's
count the number of edges
so to do this we need to remember a
pentagon has five sides right so for
each pentagon we get five edges
a hexagon has six sides so for each
hexagon we get six edges
that total is not quite right though
because if you look at one of these
edges on the soccer ball it's actually
on two different faces so when we did
this count we counted all of the edges
twice
so we need to divide the total by two to
get the actual number of edges because
like this edge is on a pentagon and a
hexagon this one's on two hexagons but
every edge is on two different
faces so we over counted so now let's
try to count the vertices the vertices
are these points at the corners
so each pentagon has five of those
each hexagon has six of those
but we over count it again so how many
did we overcount by this time
well
look at this vertex so how many times do
we count that well i counted it on this
pentagon this hexagon and this hexagon
so it was counted three times and we
really only want to count each vertex
once so i divide my total by three
okay so what do we have i have counted
my faces edges and vertices and now i'm
going to use the euler characteristic
which tells me that the number of
vertices minus the number of edges plus
the number of faces
has to be two
okay so let's do the math so
the number of vertices was 5p plus 6h
divided by 3
minus the number of edges which was 5p
plus 6h divided by 2
plus the number of faces which was p
plus h i'm just plugging in all these
things
has to be equal to 2.
so now this is an algebra problem so
let's
multiply everything by 6 to get rid of
these denominators so
when i do that over here i get 10 p plus
12 h minus 15 p minus
18 h
plus 6 plus 6h equals 12.
multiply both sides by 6.
now this looks a little better so let's
figure out what we've got i've got 10p
minus 15p is negative 5p plus 6p is just
p
12 h minus 18 h plus 6 h is 0
and i get p is equal to 12.
so what did we just learn we just showed
that there have to be 12 pentagons on
our soccer ball and it follows from that
that with this standard pattern that we
have on soccer balls that there are
going to be 20 hexagons
where did that come from
so where it comes from if we look at our
soccer ball is that each pentagon is
surrounded by five hexagons right so if
we have 12 pentagons
times five
is 60
except it's one of these over counting
things again so like this hexagon was
counted around this pentagon this
pentagon and this pentagon so it was
counted three times so we divide that by
three
and we get our 20 hexagons
so we just use the euler characteristic
to show that a standard soccer ball
tiling has to have 12 pentagons and 20
hex guns
it would have been quicker just to count
them
yeah that's true
but we've shown that it has to be true
they are in black
and 20 hexagon faces there they are in
white and they fit together and this is
your traditional football